women in Saudi Arabia finally have the
right to drive after decades of protest
Saudi Arabia was the last country in the
world to prohibit females from driving
women still need a male Guardians
consent for some activities in the
ultra-conservative nation
Kali Williams spoke to people protesting
the driving ban during her last visit to
Saudi Arabia and she joins us from
Istanbul Turkey Holly good morning good
morning a group of very brave very
determined Saudi Arabian women have been
fighting for the right to drive for over
two decades and they have finally won
but change has been painfully slow and
they're still denied many other freedoms
this is how the women protested inside
their ultra conservative Islamic Kingdom
illegally taking the wheel and posters
bandulus videos online risking arrest in
doing so mocking a system that reduced
them to children in Saudi Arabia in 2014
we met some of the women who dared to
criticize the authorities car for the
Saudi women have become the symbol of
wanting our voices to be heard and our
needs to be heard it's like in your life
in books you can't apply thing books but
now Saudi Arabia's government seems to
be modernizing just last week women were
allowed into the national sports stadium
for the first time a Saudi spokeswoman
explained the changes to the rules on
driving I think this is a victory for us
but I think it's a victory that we were
already kind of winning in a lot of
other areas if you will and so this is
just another step in the march towards
progress inside Saudi Arabia though
there's still opposition one Muslim
cleric recently claimed that women
shouldn't drive because many of them
only have a quarter of a brain
the Kings decree is the latest in a
series of gradual reforms including
permitting women to vote in local
elections and allowing girls to play
sport at school Gayle's alright
sign of the times thank you very much
Holly Williams reporting from Istanbul